I
hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcasts applying a multi omics
approach to tumour biomarker discovery
case studies I am Christina Mahalo
collaborates and I'll be your moderator
for today's events we are delighted to
bring you this educational seminar
presented by lab roads and sponsored by
at the metrics at the metrics
technologies enable multiplex in
simultaneous analysis of biological
systems at the cell protein and gene
level facilitating rapid transition a
vision research into clinical routine
into clinical in routine use for human
health and wellness affymetrix part of
thermo fisher scientific provides a
leadership and support partnering with
customers in pharmaceutical diagnostics
in biotechnology companies and leading
academic government and nonprofit
research institutes in their quest to
use biology for a better world to learn
more visit at the metrics com we have a
few important announcements before we
begin this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the advance you can
submit the questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can at the end of our presentations
today additionally you can enlarge the
slide window that you're viewing it by
clicking on the screen icon located in
the lower right-hand corner of the side
window and if you have any technical
technical problems viewing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support button located at the top right
of your presentation window or if you
like you can submit your problem through
the green Q&A button
once again located on your lower left of
the screen we are happy to say that this
is an educational webinar and thus
offers free continuing education credits
after the webinar is over please click
on the c/e button located in the bottom
left hand corner of your web page and
follow the process of obtaining your
credits I would now like to introduce
today's speakers Antonio Sepulveda yang
Yang and Tamara luton dr. Antonio
sepulveda received her MD from the
University of Lisbon and her PhD degree
from Baylor met College of Medicine she
is professor of pathology and cell
biology vice chair for transitional
research and director of the division of
gastrointestinal pathology at Columbia
University I will now turn it over to
dr. sepulveda for her portion of the
presentation dr. thank you thank you for
the introduction are very pleased to
present our studies today we will report
the results on our project that is
focused on to the expression alterations
in pancreatic cancer which enjoyed
values feedback throughout the talk
today and pre-cancer lesions when we did
this assay is identified by a human
transcriptome oh right technology so
there are about 46,000 cases of
pancreatic cancer each year and the
five-year survival for these two is
pretty dismal with twenty fourteen
percent rather of survival for stage 1
tumors early tumors and one percent for
advanced stage cancers the detection of
pancreatic cancer at surgically
resectable stage or as
cancellations is the most important
factor for improving survival rates in
addition screaming what surveillance
biomarkers to detect precancerous ins in
and the early stages of feedback are
really not available in our Creator
created so think really cancer develops
through a stepwise progression at least
about logic changes of the duct
epithelium from the normal top which we
can see on the left hand side of the
slide moving through the early stage of
pancreatic injury opportunity or
pleasure or famine and then progressing
to increasing grade and eventually
invasive adenocarcinoma studies have
shown that low-grade pennants were
detected in about sixteen percent of
normal controls and in sixty percent of
chronic pancreatitis that word for an
eighty-two percent from patients with a
pancreatic cancer I'm hearing that I
might need to turn my mic down a little
bit old eyes for that
into here okay so um so in jail there's
still a limited data what the rates of
progression of premium plastic region
pattern too invasive pancreas cancer but
the studies have estimated a one percent
probability of a single pendant elysian
to progress to invasive cancer I've
given this low rate of progression and
the fact that we do not now
histologically which cases not progress
of molecular biomarkers to predict
progression to bedeck are very needed at
this point so at the inside of this
study our working hypothesis were
multiple and first we hypothesize that
the differentially expressed genes in
henan and feedback has compared to
normal gut epithelium may represent
biomarkers for the development of
malignancy and therefore they may be
good biomarkers for early detection or
for risk assessment of progression to
pancreatic adenocarcinoma our second
hypothesis was that differentially
expressed genes in pedic as compared to
pennant and normal duct may represent
potential biomarkers for diagnosis of
malignancy and simply are altered genes
made functional roles in central
regulatory pathways may be targets for
PDF therapies
in order to profile the docto epithelium
we decided to use LCM because this would
allow us to separate the doctor
epithelium from the highly heterogeneous
background of increased issue that is
awake not normal duct epithelium blow
repellent and invasive pancreatic
adenocarcinoma epithelium so it looks
like we can see on the upper panels the
stained sections these are from frozen
tissue stem grade class of violets for
representative areas from a normal dog
pen and the pea back and the lower three
panels we can see the corresponding
areas after LCM demonstrating that we
could enrich the specimen to near purity
so today I would like to report the
results of them by coming from 22 frozen
samples which includes 9p Dec 5 pennants
and eight normal dots and importantly
this come from three rows of samples
that represent a concurrent or lesions
from the same patient so we had 33 years
of Fedak pennant and mahmuda we have to
do two rows of P back and paedon and
four duels our feedback and normal.dot
from the same patient the table on the
right summarizes the concentration and
total amount of RNA from each sample
that we used before the HDA essays and
we can see that these are in the low
range Lana Graham level so this slide
summarizes the workflow following the
recommended steps in the genechip wtp
collagen kit this is a two day procedure
in which we first obtain our cdna and
perform amplification of CRNA and in the
second day amplification
and labeling of fragmented single
stranded cdna is them fooled by a
hybridization we use the human just
ripped on to point over a and after
organization does the arrays were
scanned in a gene chips can after which
a QC and I remained organization will
perform but with the expression console
software the analysis was then done with
the transcriptome analysis console and
our approaches are including our
packages and these are still a
preliminary early beta so we are
continuing continuing our analysis now
at this slide shows on figure a above
the relative probe so intensity before
normalization whereas figure the the
graph on the lower part of the slide you
chose a relative probes out this
intensity after LMA this stands for
robust multirate average normalization
so where the normalized data were used
in subsequent analysis using the TAC
version 3.1 the as you can see in the
graph the millions of all samples are
weeping bombs and the simples that
represent the adenocarcinoma tissues are
indicated by the arrows here on the
slide
yeah I need to click one more time yes
so then we did the principal component
analysis and we can see that it did not
show significant batch of fact as
exemplified in this case with the groups
of feedback and pennant end of note the
clustering of feedback is nicely
separated from the pennant samples in
blue over as the cancer is in red that
and this provides confidence to the
purity of our samples and robustness of
the data because these are two different
biological steps in the cancer
progression so we also did clustering by
Pearson correlation of normalized
signals and in this particular slide
wanted to a highlight of the that effect
that occurred when we are included in
the analysis a subgroup of simples the
fraud were obtained from formalin-fixed
paraffin-embedded tissue also we have
two patients with three years of sample
so total of six FFPE samples and we are
on separate analysis ffpe the essays are
performed well they clearly show a batch
of fact as compared to the frozen
section sample so for subsequent
analysis we excluded the FFPE samples
and when we did that as we can see in
this slide now we do not see any obvious
batch of fat
so we studied our noses using standard
before criteria which included the up or
down regulation at twofold level and a
nova at significance of us than point 05
and in doing so are we identified over
two thousand genes at which you can see
em indicated on the right side of the
summary in this slide now when we
started looking at the individual groups
and if you look at the the lower part of
the slide of the number five we can see
that the most frequent alteration for
the comparison of panel versus a la mode
up was up regulation of 433 change this
is inside the red circle however when we
then compared to my versus permanent or
normal under three and four also I
within the red circle or we can could
see that the most frequent operation was
gene regulation so we got changed the
evoke change to 1.5 in our criteria
because we wanted to identify a Joe
scripts that work similarly altered in a
penance or in panels and two month and
so in in doing so we ended up finding 16
Christian scripts that were overlapping
intimate panin as compared to normal
done and these are possible candidate
biomarkers of neoplastic progression of
North Monday's there were 40 coding
genes that we are further looking into
the as expected based on the initial
analysis a larger number of decreased
our scripts that were commonly decreased
into my own pattern and that's shown in
this slide in the center in the pink
area
so we then the pathway analysis using
the TCC software and these obviously
showed several significantly affected
pathways in this slide we show an
example um which represents a gastric
cancer network path way in which we can
see that on the left side for pen in the
right side for feedback there are genes
that are similarly upregulated in
pennant and p dec such as s100 p whereas
there are other genes that are primarily
increased in expression such as CN PF
keith to 20 b and TP x2 there are
primarily a prevalent in tumor but not
in panin and you can see that looking at
the red circles on the right and right
side the diagram network in addition to
the TAC software um we have also used
the assigned algorithm for pathway
analysis or this algorithm uses a
Bayesian approach to assign numeric
scores to individual samples that
reflect pathway activity and the
difference is intensely activity between
groups were then tested with the kruskal
will is nonparametric tests so in this
slide we are showing an example of a
pathway the nuclear receptor pathway
that show differential expression in
pandan MP dak compared to normal using
this algorithm we can see in the graph
in the middle lower part of the slide
normal permanent and cancer a normal
duct in green the Penan in blue and the
cancer in light blue and here we
see that overall this pathway is greatly
reduced in pancreatic ductal
adenocarcinoma as compared to panel and
normal at high significance I'm using
gene signatures are derived from cell
culture the right cancer pathways we can
see app regulation of well-known
pathways such as razz which is a typical
best way that's altered in almost nearly
all the pancreatic cancers Sark and meet
pathways some of these in subsets of pdx
and also we can see correlation between
activation of these pathways
predominantly for the sarc Adweek
pathway which is at the lower right to
hand side of the slide these are
additional examples of other
differentially expressed pathways and if
you look at the lower panels in the
slide in the middle for example it is
not surprising that the cell cycle
checkpoints upregulated in pdx they're
suspending and normal now in recent
studies are integrated analysis of pedic
gene expression and genomic alterations
reported the 32 recurrently mutated
genes in 10 pathways and importantly in
our analysis we found a number of these
pathways to be altered as well giving us
confidence that our data a robust and
are in line with other studies although
there are significant differences in
methodology because we use LCM and in
these other studies both tissue was used
so we feel that our data might be more
representative of the biological process
so summarizing our findings we are found
that there were over 500 genes are
regulated in pattern compared to normal
pancreatic ducts for tumor versus
Pellinore normal.dot the most frequent
alteration however was Jim doll
regulation we found 60 genes with
increased transcripts overlapping
2-minute pen and tissues as compared to
normal dots among which there were 40
coding genes and these are a possible
candidate biomarkers for assessing that
neoplastic progression and may be useful
for early detection of pancreatic cancer
on pathway analysis we have shown
several pathways with significantly
different activity between pedic pennant
and normal duct including previously
reported pathways in AP deck and these
provide opportunities for functional
analysis and interrogation of potential
targets for therapy so finally and most
importantly I want to acknowledge the
members of our research team Elena
commisar ova George Sepulveda sellwood
can conquer and miriam shirazi as well
as the personalized genomic a laboratory
at columbia university and additionally
i would like to acknowledge that the
study are received funding from an
affymetrix tumor profiling grant thank
you for listening
thank you dr. cipota for that
informative presentation and now I'd
like to introduce dr. yang yang dr. yang
Yang received her PhD from nan Chi
University she is currently an assistant
professor in the department of
obstetrics gynecology and reproductive
sciences at the Yale School of Medicine
dr. yang yang please proceed with your
portion of the presentation hi it's my
pleasure to be invited just before my I
start I can see my slice on the screen
can anyone help me okay got it thank you
very much so this is actually my first
time presenter work through a lack wood
and I mean it's my first time I can I
can share my research which the
researcher from all over the world from
my office so I'm quite excited for this
I want to first if this is a project we
started with the support from Earth
metrics and with the tumor profiling
grant we were able to profile a 30-hour
in cancer samples and I'm going to share
some of the data and before I share the
data a little background about ovarian
cancer our in cancer is a very little
disease and the survival rate hasn't
been improved in the last 30 20 to 30
years the main challenge were in cancer
treatment and
detection is this is a different disease
we still don't have very good method to
detect and earlier and as soon as the
patient in its diagonals they will
receive standardized chemotherapies and
after several cycle treatment patient
may become dizzy free but the majority
of ovarian cancer patients will develop
recurrent disease the recurrent disease
early are very rich listen to all the
the conventional therapies so our
challenge is how we can treat these or
we can pre when the recurrent disease
and the so that's the focus of my
research in the past few years since
line moving so one of the reason why our
anchors are so difficult to treat and
detect is because our in cancer is such
a complicated disease it can develop
from multiple origins and based on the
subtype of our in cancer they have very
different genetic background and
pathological features so in past few
years our study and we start to
understand not only this general Erin
cancer is a many type of disease also
you know sometimes in one patient one
tumor you can detect very complex
population so the orange hue murder
heterogeneity it's also one of the
problem we have to face and when we
develop new therapy you want in our
study we discover well we isolate a
population of are in cancer cells they
express a high level of cd44 and the
mighty 88 and when we inject these
cancer cells into animal they can form
tumor and in the tumor form in mice we
can detect both cd44 mediate
positive position under negative
population and if we look into their
gene expression the positive population
they express high level offer and stem
cell consistent markers when they become
the negative population they love these
markers lower we further categorize the
difference between these two populations
and not only their mythology also many
other cellular functions for example
here and I hope you can appreciate this
picture there's a dramatic difference
between these two picture so the picture
on the left is the cells with city 44
and which can form tumor in matrigel
they can grow into a web-like structure
but when they become they lose cd44 and
they don't have the ability to survive
from this structure of course we also
checked their tumor forming ability only
the cells maintain order and occurs they
can form tumor when they lose market II
don't want to my anymore so is it
possible these you need a population of
a standard or in cancer style they are
the cancer stem cells as a possible they
are the cells you can really regulate
and recurrent and resistant to therapies
and we are conducting more studies to
further under understand all these
markers of course other groups studying
our in cancer they are using different
cell surface marker cd44 and many other
markers I believe we are looking at
different population you know in cancer
this disease is far more complicated
than we thought before and in our
therapy development study if we try to
mimic the real tumor than mixing these
two different population self we label
them with different fluorescent protein
here you can see when we treat these
this
extra of our in cancer cells with
conventional therapies and the stem cell
population they survive the green cells
only the red cells and the cells lost
themselves markers they are killed by
conventional therapy and this is a
lovely story is a another compound which
target p53 pathway you can see this
compound is also not very effective at
killing all the cancer cells so during
our study we discover some new compound
which have the potential to eliminate
those cell population showing here this
is one of the compound and it can kill
both cell population hopefully in the
future we can use this kind of drug and
to help patient so to summarize what I
just described in other in cancer it is
or I will say in many other type of
cancer and it's possible the primary
tumor was already a mixed cell
population and during the therapy a lot
of style they are sensitive to therapy
they are eliminated but the stem cell
the more resistance doubt they survive
are not only survived because they have
very unstable genome they may gain more
mutation during the chemo and then and
develop into a many new population you
are more complex more resistant tumor
this may explain what happened in many
patients after many years maybe they
recur after the dormancy period and
these tumor become more aggressive so
what are the molecular pathway behind
this transition this progression and
we're still in the process of
understanding the mechanism one of the
out the goal of our research is to
understand what happened during this
process but because now we're really
limited by our knowledge and sometimes
is really difficult to get tissue
samples so now
our study star was getting a piece of
primary tumor and then the recurrent
tumor after during this process there's
a lot of things happened we still have
difficulty to capture at the different
stages so is the support from at the
matrix we were able to use both DNA and
the Arnold Lee so why I chose DRA UNKLE
skeem there's a rhythm so this is a
recent paper published in Nature
Genetics they actually study this group
studied many different type of cancer
and their conclusion is all these
different type of cancer can divide it
into two types one type here are showing
summarizing here are mutation driven
class and the second class is copy
number alteration type of cancer our in
cancer is right here actually the top
one so in other hands are especially the
most aggressive type high-grade serous
ovarian cancer copy number variation
have a number game and lost a very
common and the frequency happen also
very high and this is why we chose UNKLE
skeem to a detector copy number
variation in as a key tissues and the in
combination will also choose a human
transcriptional ray to study the army
and hopefully we can find some
correlation between the NRA and find
some target or some important pathway to
explain this molecular mechanism and so
according to our experience working with
the automatic here we try to follow the
instructions very strict me but it is
really challenging when you work with
clinical samples sometimes you don't get
enough tissue sometimes you want it to
be very fresh but the experiment process
may get delayed so this is our
experience we were able to get REM
DNA from one sample 10 slides or three
pieces of time mi quang ninh slides from
parent blogs and some tumor at really
small size tumors including some of the
data I'm going to share a from an animal
human xenografts some of the tissue are
very old average I think six years old
tissue some tissue are from pain from
ten maybe ten years old and this is the
the Challenger would have to face
because our in cancer as I mentioned
many patiently their disease recur like
six seven years later so when you get
the secondary to Mar the primary Omar
person a blog it's at least six seven
years old and another Widow which holds
ankle skin is we really like the
software it's really easy to use it
doesn't take a lot of time to learn how
to use it and they're very comprehensive
information and some time is so easy you
can from the view of the whole genome
and they really zoom into each gene and
it's directly linked to the function and
the publications related to this gene so
it's really a facilitate our study so
here I'm showing some examples as i
mentioned high-grade serous have our in
cancer is the most aggressive they have
a lot of copy number variation here we
are showing a patient a and ABI e so
this patient a on the upper panel here
and has a lot of copy number gang happy
number loss and the yellow party label
is the loh and so this is a typical a
high-grade serous type or anticipation
another patient you can see the lower
panel i'm showing here as an example to
compare with this is also a rank
inserted by the different type and you
can see the copy number are quite
different so by uncle's can we can
distinguished even type of our enhancer
and the next example i'm showing here
and this is a Hydra terrorists have
already cancer same patient primary
tumor and the recurrent suma Lord panel
you can see the overview this is a
salary of ankle skin data a lot of
regional copy number gain in blue and
coffee another loss in red and a lot of
yellow parts loh and when the TD recur
in general you'll see they look very
similar but if you zoom in look into the
details there's another way to show this
is the same patient data I'd put it in a
different format and by the way all
these figures are generated from the
Nexus the software so here you can see
the look very similar you can tell this
in from the same patient but if you look
closer and the primary tumor in this
region their work common on three
there's copy number game but it's not
detect detected it's not in the
recurrent Schumer and here there's a
copy number loss and it's not in the
secondary humor so actually there is a
shift of the the cell population in a
tumor and something has changed and so
we did the ankle seein for all the 30
tumor samples paired samples and we also
use the executive same paraffin slam
holes from the same sample we extract
RNA and we want HTA and this is a
summary of all the 30 samples and you
can see all these region label red or
green they are the differential
significantly differentially expressed
genes and or transcripts and they how
they localize in the genome so it's a
lot of data we are still in the process
of analyzing understanding the data some
claim array
and analysis are already very
interesting for example here when we
compare all the we get all the genes
copy number of variations from BNI data
analyze the pathway we also do a similar
with RNA now it's a very simple analysis
but if you look into the pathway there
are very important pathway well-known
has we play important role in cancer
like Zelda cell survival there are also
pathway analysis is new to me like your
system developer related this is in the
top five and the info in the IRA data
will also found a neurological disease
related this is surprised me our own
cancer haven't been related to a neural
system related G in our pathway is it
possible this is something we should
look into or is it an architect from the
test we are doing more and validation to
confirm this data and so as I said we
are trying to understand this disease
progression process and we ask more
questions is it possible using the
technology using a model we have we take
a primary tumor from the patient and buy
used using a xenograft model or unit
remodel we treat each tumor and try to
select the resistant the cancer stem
cell population and I understand this
population it's a possible we predict
what are the pathway going to control
this disease progression and it's going
to be the resistant pathway in the
registers of disease so is it possible
to predict the resistance and to try to
approve this a possibility we use or try
to use animal model of the tested while
experiment we did is we mouse we inject
humor or in cancer cells and you can see
they are
I've always fluorescent and they develop
into very aggressive tumor if we don't
treat them if we treat with paclitaxel
and our my station they become
physically but after some time these
tumor recur if you don't treat them they
will become very aggressive again what
if you treat them and these two will
become resistant they don't we stand any
more like the primary disease so this is
actually very similar to what happen
human patients and we were able to use
this model on different drugs here's one
of the data we got from the xenograft a
mouse model you can see the early tumor
and the late humor and they look similar
there are big regions are poor copy
number alterations and there are also
some region if you zoom in and they are
game when you know the much later stage
of and these tumors we also detect human
of the population cells with Kara's
notation when we conduct this similar
study with different drugs including the
new compound I mentioned earlier you can
see a very different DNA copy number
profile here and actually the taxa which
is show in the animal model and in which
remodel very efficient treatment and
they actually alter the genome the most
you can see all the speak regions and
you zoom in you will find even more
different genes different copy numbers
and surprisingly the drug we are testing
the new drug and it costs the genomic
alteration the least and we still try to
understand how this drug work why and
the genome is not changed as much as the
conventional therapy so when we put
other genes which are significantly
change both a DNA copy number level and
the eye level with I'm very interesting
password including
um here i'll surprise the auburn cancer
signaling related genes and pathways
here in the center and we also find the
M&P family related pathway and l6
signaling pathway l6 is a very important
passage ovarian cancer and those yeah
and the hip wat r for signaling pathway
this is related to the metastasis and
especially for our in cancer but has it
happened in the peritoneal cavity and
the a lot of environmental factor are
hipocrita related he was out the past
week and play an important role and this
is the iron data we found some pathway
our quarry a correlated to the DNA copy
number data we found also new passage
like cxcr4 signaling pathways and in EGF
pathways so sometimes I passed it again
in mouse model we see similar as human
model as I mentioned the very important
and tumor related password and again the
numeral system related parsley here and
here in our data so now our lab we we
are really interested in color
validating the data and try to conform
these data in a more detailed and
functional level so our vision is it in
the future based on more our improve
knowledge of this disease and new models
new tech techniques as a possible we
will predict the recurrent disease and
even develop or screen for therapies
that can target the recurrent easy so
before the recurrent easy happen we can
already have these drugs prepared for
the patient or one step quarter maybe we
can use these new drugs to prevent the
return of disease and
as a chemo prevention approach so to
summarize we have used or we have been
using as a matrix after PE for uncle
scare and HCA array and now we are using
the quanta gene multiplex and try to
conform some of the genes that are
differentially expressed from the array
data in the end I want to thank at
matrix a lot of colleagues they support
our research and give us the technical
support and including data analysis and
and thank you for this opportunity thank
my collaborators I have seen all our the
number of our attendees are increasing I
helped some of my collaborators are also
looking at this presentation and I would
like to get your feedback for our
research thank you thank you for your
back in from informative presentation
dr. yang Yang next is it is my pleasure
to introduce dr. tamara lutsen dr.
tamara layton received her MD degree
from the University of Chicago fits a
Pittsburgh School of Medicine she is
currently an associate professor of
pathology in oncology at the john
hopkins university school of medicine
doctor lives and the floor is yours
great thanks very much let me get my
slides excellent so thanks for this
opportunity to present our research and
I'm going to tell you a little bit today
about some work we've been doing on
integrated genomic profiling of primary
prostate cancer which we hope will
eventually be useful both for prognosis
and for prediction so prostate cancer is
a clinically and genetically
heterogeneous disease and this has
really been a challenge in trying to
study it and treat it and we know that
some prostate tumors are quite indolent
will grow very slowly and the patient
will likely die of other causes even
though they have prostate cancer and
these tumors really shouldn't be treated
on the other hand we know that a number
of tumors are lethal and require pretty
aggressive therapy at the outset and
distinguishing between these two
different populations of tumors has been
a challenge we have some morphologic or
pathologic criteria that help us to make
this distinction but there's really been
an active search for biomarkers
particularly molecular biomarkers that
might help pathologists to distinguish
between these lethal and indolent
subtypes of prostate cancer so we've and
others have felt for a long time that
developing a molecular taxonomy of
prostate cancer will be critical to
minimizing disease over treatment on the
one hand and also to realizing the
promise of precision medicine for
patients with advanced diseases and a
number of large-scale efforts have been
have taken place related characterized
the genome of human prostate cancer
probably the largest effort in primary
prostate cancer has been the Cancer
Genome Atlas and at this point we know
very well what the common and uncommon
molecular subtypes of primary prostate
cancer are but a challenge has been that
the efforts such as the Cancer Genome
Atlas although they very carefully
molecularly subtype large cohorts of
prostate cancer patients do not
generally have large amounts of
come data or very high quality clinical
or pathologic annotations so it's been
very hard to map back these molecular
subtypes onto the you know on to
outcomes data and so our challenge or we
feel a challenge has really been to make
the molecular technology which we now
understand and prostate cancer
clinically relevant hopefully by
integrating much of this
multi-dimensional cancer genomics data
with a very highly annotated cohort of
clinical pathologic specimens where we
have very high quality annotations and
can try to understand what the meaning
is of these molecular subclasses for
patient outcomes so I guess as as dr.
yang has nicely pointed out their
cancers can sort of be divided between
those where the copy number alterations
prevail and mutations prevail prostate
cancer I guess much like ovarian cancer
is one of the solid tumors in which copy
number alterations really prevail over
mutations and here are two actually
relatively older study some of the
earliest studies looking at copy number
across different prostate cancer cohorts
on the right side of the screen you can
actually see an advanced cohort of
prostate cancer patients with metastatic
and lethal disease taken at autopsy and
you can see that the copy number gains
and losses which are denoted in blue and
red dots really prevail over mutations
across the gene sequence in this in this
whole exome sequencing study mutations
are noted in yellow orange and green on
the left side of this of the screen you
can see the typical copy number
landscape of primary prostate cancer so
we have typically gains of chromosome 8
q for instance where mick is located
losses of chromosome 10 Q where P 10 is
located losses of chromosome 13 q where
r b1 is located an on/off often frequent
losses on chromosome 17 at the tp53
locus so we understand this this
spectrum of copy number alterations and
now I think the challenge is to really
integrate that with clinical outcomes
data and then also also with RNA
expression and protein expression data
to develop better prognostic classifiers
to apply to prostate cancer biopsy
specimens so we undertook a study to
begin to do this kind of work using a
cohort of specimens from the Johns
Hopkins Brady urological Institute so we
have a large biospecimen repository here
of primary prostate cancer would
arguably among the highest quality and
it's certainly most extensive clinical
annotations available and so we were
interested now in mapping back these
known molecular subtypes of prostate
cancer which have been described in
efforts such as the TCGA on to our
cohort where we have excellent clinical
and pathologic annotations to try to
understand how these genomic alterations
correlate with outcomes and so we
propose to develop something we would
call the Brady genomics portal which
would be an internal database enabling
Hopkins researchers to query that the
tumor cohorts that we have in house in
terms of their genomic profiles with
both genomic and transcriptomic
profiling available so the cohort we
started with is one that's actually been
previously published by Ashley Ross is a
urologist at our institution the
reference is down in the lower
right-hand portion of the screen visco
war consists of around 350 radical
prostatectomy specimens all
formalin-fixed and paraffin-embedded
there were all performed or removed from
the patients between 1992 and 2010 so
relatively older cohort and this means
that we have a median of 10 years of
clinical follow-up on the majority of
the specimens and the outcome that was
queried for was metastasis which is
really considered the gold standard in
evaluating prostate cancer outcomes one
other advantage of this cohort is that
none of the patients in the cohort
received any treatment after between the
time of radical prostatectomy and the
time eventual time of
detection of metastasis so it's
considered to be a natural history
cohort in the sense that patients
received only surgical treatment with no
adjuvant chemotherapy or radiation which
might make discerning the natural
history of those cases difficult one
other advantage of the cohort is our
colleague George Neto in pathology here
had already regraded and restaged all of
the cases in this cohort using the most
updated a pathologic criteria and that
was reported in a plus one paper in 2016
and we went ahead and sampled the
dominant nodule and quadruplicate from
all these cases for both DNA previously
RNA extraction had already been done
from the same tumor nodules and tmas had
also been prepared by dr. Neto and his
team tmas meaning tissue microarrays I
should clarify so a little bit of this
work has has already been presented this
is actually I forgot to put the
reference in the lower corner but this
is a paper by Michael Johnson in our
institution in the journal of urology
which was published this year in 2016
looking at the ability to use the RNA
profiling from this cohort which have
been completed on the affymetrix one
point OST arrays to predict for one of
the most common genomic rearrangements
and prostate cancer which is a
rearrangement in the one of the x family
acha genes it's ets family acha genes
and the most commonly rearranged gene is
the urging you can see on the left-hand
panel that when the urging is real is
rearranged either by a deletion or
translocation it's then under control of
an androgen regulated promoter typically
at expression increases dramatically so
we can just we can detect the presence
of these underlying genomic
rearrangements just by the RNA
expression or protein expression of AG
acha gene and you can see that about
half of the cases had underlying
rearrangements as evidenced by this
increased org expression which is what
we expected
perhaps more importantly we don't have
good antibodies to detect rearrangements
of the other X family oncogene such as
etv one which is depicted here and so
RNA levels can be used to infer the
rearrangement status of these cases you
can see that a subpopulation of cases
less than ten percent as expected had
overexpression UTV one suggesting an
underlying etv one genomic rearrangement
and tumors with or etv one
rearrangements constitute probably the
main known molecular subclass of
prostate cancers so we were interested
in taking this one step further and
looking at the expression of these X
family genes to make these rearrangement
calls inside to in small quantities of
tissue so we used the affymetrix view
RNA and a combination of also the ACG
RNA scope technology to do RNA insight
to hybridization for the 3x family genes
etv one etv for Andy tv5 for which we
don't have good antibodies for detection
so RNA really remains our only available
tool to look at overexpression of these
of these genes and again overexpression
tightly correlates to rearrangement of
the underlying genomic locus and leading
to androgen regulated overexpression of
these oncogenes and so you can see here
we have some examples depicted of rich
for et v5e TV 42 b1 the top row on the
left on the left panel depicts cases
that were positives you can see the red
dots indicate positive positive
detection of these RNA molecules in the
cancer cells and you can see intervening
benign glands which are negative and
just blue as we would expect and the
bottom row shows you some cases that
were negative and then the right-hand
panel shows a nice correlation between
the calls for etv one rearrangements
that were made based on the rich or the
RNA insight to hybridization which was
done on these tissue microarrays
compared to the etv one expression
levels seen
by the the a fee one point OST array
transcriptomic profiling and you can see
that there's a very high correlation
there were only two discordant cases in
the entire cohort so we can very nicely
classify these cases either by grinding
up the tissue and doing transcriptomic
profiling or perhaps even more easily by
doing insight to hybridization for these
transcripts in addition on this cohort
we looked to see whether known that
genetically validated
immunohistochemical biomarkers and
prostate cancer were performing as we
expected them to here we're showing
immunised or chemistry for p53 which is
fairly sensitive and specific for the
presence of an underlying p53 missense
mutation which leads to stabilization of
the protein and you can see that in this
cohort sort of as a sanity check we
could tell that the in the in the right
hand panel at cases with p53 over
expression which have known mutations in
the gene in the p53 gene have a worse
outcome in terms of a cumulative
incidence and metastasis in this cohort
as we would expect so again just sort of
us a check to make sure that everything
looks reasonable in terms of the
correlation of known genomic biomarkers
of outcome in the cohort so next what we
wanted to do was gather a relatively
high resolution whole genome copy number
analysis or copy number profiling on all
of these formalin-fixed
paraffin-embedded prostate cancers
primary tumors that were in the current
cohort and so we really needed to find a
platform that worked in FFPE samples
which was challenging and one that
required relatively low DNA inputs and
we had relatively older samples and so
we tried out the affymetrix acha scan
platform and we've actually had very
nice success or that we've profiled I
think almost 50 cases to date and we've
had a relatively low failure rate in the
figure depicted on the slide you can see
a typical copy number pro
file of a typical case with for instance
a gain on chromosome 8 q and the
including the mick locus and then a very
with the arrow showing a very specific
and focal loss a deep deletion of the
p10 a tumor suppressor gene and below
you can see the b allele plot to get a
better sense of some of these gains and
losses across the chromosome so this
slide shows a sort of a general
landscape of copy number alterations we
found by acha scan in the first 50
primary prostate tumors that we profiled
it looks very similar to one of the
earlier figures i showed you from
previous work and again the key is not
to make some new discoveries in terms of
copy number alterations because these
are very well known in prostate cancer
but now to really link them to outcomes
which we can finally do with this cohort
so again you could see common losses at
8p gains at 8q as i mentioned we're
common specific losses at the p10 locus
at 10 q etc in this in this plot so it
looks pretty similar to what we would
expect as an additional validation of
some of the specific copy number calls
that were made in the aqha scan platform
we correlated with genetically validated
insight to and sequencing assays that we
had performed in the lab on the same
cases so for example we have an immune
history chemistry assay or an IHC sa 4
p-10 and you can see an example of that
depicted in the figure on the slide the
right hand spot shows a tumor area
depicted by the letter T with pete n
protein loss which makes the tumor of
your blue compared to the surrounding
benign glands which are labeled with
Abby you can see nice dark brown
staining such a suggesting underlying
p10 protein presence and those that
tumor the tumor sample on the left has
no loss of pten at the protein level
based on the fact that the tumor and the
benign glands have fairly similar levels
of expression so it turned out that
ninety six percent of the cases it had
p10 copy number loss by august can
a profiling showed protein loss by IHC
importantly a hundred percent of the
cases that had homozygous copy number
loss had complete protein loss and then
we also saw that in among cases with
known PT p53 missense mutations which we
knew by a sequencing panel performed on
these same samples 75% of them should
copy number loss presumably at the other
allele of p53 in the same case as we
would have been expecting so this was a
nice validation of some of the specific
copy number calls in on this platform so
finally we're hard at work now trying to
integrate all of the RNA profiling with
the DNA copy number profiling data and
then some of the RNA insight to and
other immunise or chemistry insight to
assays into a database that can be
queried by researchers at our
institution so you can see here this is
a instance with the help of dr. Alex
Barris who's also in the pathology
department at Johns Hopkins we've been
working on implementing a very local
instance of the sea vaio portal database
which is the database developed at
memorial sloan-kettering and used to
report out most of the TCGA studies we
have a local instance of that same
database you can see with the clinical
outcome information annotated pathologic
stage grade race of the tumors annotated
and now we've integrated for the first
50 cases we've done these copy number
profiles into that same database and
we're at work now putting in the RNA
expression profiling from the a fee st
arrays and then also as some of the
images of chemistry profiling and it's
our hope that at that point we can begin
to integrate so DNA RNA and protein data
to sort of design an optimal and
potentially clinically implementable
biomarker panel to predict adverse
outcomes in prostate cancer so once we
complete copy number alteration out
analysis on the remaining samples and we
have about two
hundred to go at this point we'll
integrate this data and the RNA
expression data as i mentioned to begin
to develop prognostic classifiers and
the idea is then to take these
classifiers and validate in prostate
tumor biopsy cohorts with outcome data
information to begin to try to
understand which patients can be safely
watched and who have genomic profiles
that suggest they need potentially
immediate treatment and I think the
ultimate goal obviously is to create
this kind of clinical classifier both
for risk assessment and then perhaps
later in progression of disease for
predictive biomarkers that may predict
efficacy of specific therapies so with
that I'll just thank the members of my
lab who worked on this and I mentioned
many of our collaborators throughout the
talk who have been very helpful and of
course the team at affymetrix and the
tumor profiling grant which was very
helpful to get started with some of this
data collection and with that I guess
we'll take some questions
thank you so much for your presentation
dr. Wooten um just enough before we get
started on the question answer session I
like to remind our audience how to
submit questions you can submit your
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the present tension of the presentation
window will try to get to as many of the
questions as possible and so let's just
go ahead and hop in and see what we what
we have today um the first question I
have is for dr. Lewton it reads what are
the clinical contexts in which copy
number alteration profiling a pro
filling could be useful in prostate
cancer management yes so that's a good
question so I think there are a number
of contexts in which we could use this
kind of technology one is in the context
of managing patients who are potential
candidates for active surveillance and
prostate cancer so these are patients
with relatively low burden of disease on
prostate biopsy low pathologic grade of
disease and well I don't think it's
likely that we will ever have enough
tumor sampled in those cases to run you
know a whole genome copy profiling test
I think we can begin to take some of the
findings from our whole genome copy
number profiling to implement very
specific copy number alteration assays
to query either insight to in the form
of fish or other types of assays in the
biopsy sample itself in in small numbers
of tumor glands we do know that the
whole hold the burden of whole genome
copy number alterations is highly
correlated in prostate
sir with adverse outcomes so it would be
nice i think in the future if we had
some ability to do more comprehensive
copy-number profiling on these very very
small tumors but right now that's
challenging i think a second context of
use is potentially in the more advanced
setting perhaps a patient who's already
undergone radical prostatectomy and
perhaps had recurrence after radical
prostatectomy there we have much more
tumor to a safe or copy number
alterations so that if we have a good
sense of specific copy number
alterations that are associated with
adverse outcome or even hopefully
specifically associated with response to
particular therapies then you can
envision a situation in which we could
clinically do hold you know copy number
profiling and ffpe material from the
radical prostatectomy to get some sense
of whether the patient is likely to
respond down the road to more targeted
therapies or protect potentially do a
similar type of test on the metastatic
sample so I think those are a couple of
context where it could be useful
clinically
excellent thank you for that answer dr.
yang we have a question for you it's
reads and asks is it sometimes difficult
to get good RNA and DNA from ffpe tissue
samples how how to improve the quality
and quantity of RNA and DNA from ffpe so
according to our it's there and it is
indeed to get a good amount of Hawaiian
DNA and also the quality so first of all
and array at the metric RNA and DNA rate
they are very sensitive they can do
really well with very small model for
the NRA so to improve the quality and
quantity adding one thing actually the
most important is if it's possible when
you collect the sample the tumor sample
when the tumor sample is still fresh and
put it in kamala high as soon as
possible as already as you can because
leaving the t show you in pds for a long
time it's not good for later there are
engineering process and after if you
already have that p sample what you can
do we improve the quality and there are
some critical steps for example and to
reduce the time your sample size and the
cut side exposed to the air in the air
reduced that time also when you extract
RNA the temperature really important and
if there's an incubation time a high
temperature incubation don't extend the
incubation longer high temperature
incubation will make the RNA year sample
into a small fragments and that's our
good either so and yeah a lot of small
details really stick to the protocols
and pay attention
to the small details I think it helps a
lot for our project thank you thank you
dr. yang Yang and since we are running
short on time we only have time for one
more question and dr. Sepulveda it will
be for you the question asks why did you
choose transcript own analysis with
their ray with the array platform as
compared to our in a sequence thank you
for that question it's quite pertinent
so we were interested in a
characterizing expression of for example
the pancreatic duct which is a very
small so population within the large
background of multiple cellular
components in the background pancreas
and in order to do so we would need to
do laser capture microdissection so
typically we laser capture
microdissection we obtain very limited
amounts of a genomic material and family
RNA and so we got then um the
consideration is um what platform to use
if you have limited amounts of material
as well as potentially the quality
because you want to bond a validation
studies we want to look to use larger
cords and expand our studies of the
paraffin fix the tissues and in those
cases specifically from paraffin it
would not be feasible to use on
platforms like RNA seek for example so
in the front using a platform that is
not very sensitive to the quality of RNA
and can perform quite well even when
a significantly degraded I we decided
that this was a good approach because it
allows us to address the engine
expression in the fresh tissue and later
on expanding expanding our studies also
to do the same analysis in the perfect
issue and therefore I will be able to
correlate our findings in this early
phase as well as with the data that you
plan to obtain later okay well thank you
so much dr. is for presenting for your
presentations I would also like to thank
our sponsor at the metrics for making
today's educational webcast possible
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through in February
2017 you will be you will receive an
email from lab roots alerting you when
the webcast is available for replay we
invite you encouraging them to share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live events
we add lab roots thank you once again
for attending it will see you next time
goodbye